do you want this giant knife that they
clearly used to break into the car and
the police like throw it away everything
just went into the trashcan
hi I'm Becky and my cholera story
happened to me I just moved out of an
ex's house we've just broken up I was
just about to start a new job so all
these big changes were happening I woke
up to go to my first day at this job and
I came out into the street there's a
very wide street with like palm trees
and like bushy trees lining the road and
then I was like why is there like a
forest in the street and I started
walking closer and closer to it I was
like huh oh it's a fallen tree but it's
huge and then I was like that's really
close to my car I realized it was very
close to my kind that it was upon my car
and nobody else's car in the whole
street just mine and this tree was like
one of those ones days like you would
draw this tree or you would paint this
tree like this is worth your time it's
huge
nice thick trunk any other situation I
don't love this tree I love a good tree
but straight across like smashing the
roof and the windshield down it was so
dramatic
first of all I have was just like this
is really embarrassing of having to be
like that one person so plotting for
Ward's of the scene like every all the
neighbors were out and they're all just
like oh my god what a catastrophe and
then there's me just like it's mine
everyone should I help but like what are
you gonna do I couldn't even have it
evaluated by the insurers because it was
covered by tree so I had to like call
the city to come and bring people in to
like remove the tree no like sawing and
life is all these like huge trucks
everywhere and then this is me barest
and the neighbors like trying to help
and all like oh yeah the soils loose
around here they're all trying to like
have me up to sue the city and they were
like yeah yeah trees always fall down
around here and they don't water them
properly so I was just getting really
mad because I believe them I tried to
contact the city about it and they just
didn't care they were like how are we to
be in control of the trees and I was
like because they're yours you planted
them
we just can't promise that I'm like if
it fell on a Children's Hospital care
then but they didn't care about my car I
literally had just bought this car I'd
spent months researching the car I
wanted to buy when I could afford one
they evaluated it it wasn't salvageable
that's sad I kind of felt like something
okay would
come out of it when I figured out how to
get replacement through my insurance I
actually got more money than the car was
worth it ended up getting a little bit
of a nicer car out of the whole thing
and it meant that I had like a clean
break spiritually because the car had
nothing to do in my ex then I got a new
apartment new job which they allowed me
to come back in because they understood
my car was under a tree you know it was
hard to fake that hi I'm Erin and I'm
gonna tell you of my worst car horror
story I came down to go to work and I
park in a gated garage underneath my
apartment building in a tandem space
with my roommate and so I walk
downstairs to get in my car and head on
to work and my roommates car is in the
most forward parking space in our tandem
spot but mine's missing initially I was
really freaked out I wasn't sure where
it went I thought maybe she moved it to
the street or something I went ahead and
called her and I was like hey did you
see my car last night
she's like yeah you didn't move it or
anything this morning did you and just
like no I was like okay well then I'm
pretty sure it got stolen so I was like
they break in my roommates car move her
car then breaking in my car take my car
and then move hers back nothing made
sense but we ended up figuring out that
my spare key was in her cup holder and
then somehow it got my car out of its
spot and out the door first things first
I called the police the police are super
doubtful they're like that doesn't
happen I understand it doesn't happen
I'm confused file a report whatever
everyone thinks that my roommates stole
it next up I call insurance insurance
it's also like that's not how cars get
stolen and I was like I understand
I'm also very confused finally I go to
my building manager and I'm like hey
this happened can you pull footage how
they would steal my car in this position
everything like that eventually my
building manager calls me and he lets me
know that one of the security guards who
patrols our area in our building saw a
tow truck come into our garage and he
suggested that I was repo'd and I was
just like there's no way and how like
you need to still pull the footage like
I need to see what actually happened he
finally sends me the footage and it's
two girls who somehow get into the
garage like either they have a code to
get in or they had a clicker I'm not
sure and they walk literally directly to
me and my roommates car and what we
ended up seeing is that like there
wasn't a car parked in the space next to
us so they were able to like turn and
get my car out through the spot next to
it and this drive out I go
about like six or seven days without a
car and I'm just kind of like waiting
for the 30 B days to pass so I could get
a brand new car was like there's no way
they're tracking this down like this
thing is so gone in the morning I
finally get a call from a police officer
like six or seven days later this is a
police officer I'm just wondering if you
were able to find you a car yet and I
was like no I haven't he's like okay
well we found it it was at a park so do
this down the street and he was like
we've been sitting on it like trying to
see if anyone's gonna come back and get
it I Drive over and the cop is just
sitting there and he hands me gloves and
says go ahead and search the vehicle and
make sure there's no drugs I was a
little thrown off I was like why don't
you do this but okay so me and my
boyfriend are looking through the car
kind of pulling out everything and what
we find is like a bunch of fast-food
bags three pairs of fake eyelashes in
the dashboard used condoms in the
cupholder a giant kitchen knife hidden
in the side there's like Poncho's they
stole everything out of the back of the
car and there were like eight bones
connected to the Bluetooth we're pulling
all this stuff out of the car and like
showing the police officer I'm like do
you want this giant knife that they
clearly used to break into the car and
the police like throw it away these used
condoms he's like throw it away finally
I'm like there's meat on the back seats
you just like brush it off everything
just went into the trashcan they were
just like case closed you're all good
give this to insurance they should cover
whatever it is that's missing so I'm not
sure exactly what happened but I think
they just had a really great week in my
car and just partied in there and then
gave it back it could have been some
illegal behavior but for a while it was
like speculation that like someone in
the building was behind it or like the
security team was behind it but like
I've decided to just let it go it was
for sure an inside job in some way but
it was my neighbor who stole my car like
I'm watching you my name is Kailyn and
today I'm gonna tell you about one of my
worst car horror stories ever and I take
this one normal very specific route the
very traffic heavy and as I was driving
down the road my car started smoking and
I was like what is going on and so I
called my dad my dad the car is on fire
what do I do and then I seen it like my
temperature gauge or whatever is all the
way at the top I got out of the car and
I was like should I open the hood so
luckily my dad called me like don't you
dare open that hood he said just give it
a second before I like try to open
anything up so then I like tried to move
my car even more to this
and I was able to like pull off to a
side street I did not have any water on
me because you're supposed to have like
water or coolant or like in your trunks
and I am getting like the basically the
middle point of being a mile or two away
from any gas station so I think I drove
like five minutes and then stopped again
cuz it started smoking and then another
five minutes and then almost got to the
gas station stopped again and it started
smoking and then drove another five
minutes finally made it to the gas
station and put coolant in there and
then it took like two hours from this
point for it to cool down enough for me
to like drive it again there's actually
a dealership nearby it was about two
miles away and it was like a 15 20
minute drive with the traffic so it's
like inching my way there literally like
a caterpillar it was like an hour long
break in between every time but I
stopped so this whole process was at
least five to six hours and basically
the dealership was already closed so I
essentially had to just like leave my
car in front of the dealership and like
hope that it didn't get towed there and
I'd called them let them know that like
that was my car out front and I needed
to be looked out because it was
overheating I do remember they said that
I essentially melted the piece that
connects the engine to the coolant I
basically did the same thing again the
next day where I drove the car for five
minutes took a break until I made it
home but it was still like a three-hour
process once again got the car home and
just like dropped it off there because
it was just like dead to me I think it
was Carles for about a week but my dad
opted off one of his cars and I have one
parking spot in my garage and I live in
a very residential neighborhood in LA so
like I never have issues with street
parking there's like no signs posted in
my neighborhood okay well I'll just move
the dead one to the street so I can like
use my parking spot like that'll be much
more convenient for me but apparently
there's a law that states that you can't
leave your car street part in the same
spot for more than 72 hours I didn't
check on the car for like a full week I
get a call from the Glendale Police
Department and they informed me that my
car had been towed and impounded so I
was stuck in Arizona for a week and my
car was essentially collecting dust and
dollars in the impound lot
yeah it's
it'd be about $1,000 to get their car at
the impound lot and I was like are you
look how much more money is this car
gonna take away from me and it's not
even a nice car I don't even need it can
you guys just keep it can you guys like
destroy it or something and they told me
that if I did that then it would like
basically like plummet my credit scores
that wasn't an option so I ended up
spending like around probably like
$1,200 just to get my dead car out of an
impound lot
it was a great experience
[Music]